but now we're joined by Magnus Carlson's
coach Peter Heinen Wilson thank you for
joining us Peter how are you
I'm fine thanks and thanks for bringing
in thank you so much for coming on and
uh well Peter I'll I'll start on the
topic that everyone is talking about
Magnus Carlsen withdrawing from the
singfield cup and resigning his game
against Hans Neiman yesterday can you
tell us why he did that
not really no uh it's surprising
decisions to me as well perhaps to some
extent but also I respect his choice not
to to talk about it and if someone from
Team Magnus who talk about it it should
obviously be macros yeah I I suspected
that of course so uh resigning yesterday
was that not something he had talked
about with you
again uh well it didn't come as a
surprise to me let's put it like that
but uh again it's uh I I mean I'm
employed by Magnus and I think it's
important to respect the the Privacy uh
he has as a coach and the sort of
confidentiality in talking to me so uh
I'm not really gonna tell you anything
there yeah